he's as artsy as his father
is fartsy
yeah the dude who used to love blow
finally opened his show but are his
paintings as abstract as the shady deals
it attracts on wednesday hunter biden
finally showed up to the new york city
art gallery where his paintings are
being offered for up to a half million
bucks a piece to buyers that are as
anonymous as tyler perry in a tyler
perry movie
the family affair was detailed by the
new york post which is owned by her
parent company virginia slims
hunter brought his wife and kids well
most of his kids joining about 60 guests
for for the private affair including one
art critic who said of hunter he's a
serious artist the work is terrific now
if you'll excuse me i've just been named
ambassador to costa rica
apparently hunter didn't uh ring up any
sales there were too many people
watching
but he already sold five prints for 75
grand each which buys a lot of coke i
mean art supplies
the post also asked hunter if he'd ever
gotten his laptop laptop back
[Music]
that was hunter's wife saying it doesn't
exist
much like hunter's qualifications for
the jobs he's had it doesn't exist it's
the same thing papa joe said in the
about the deuce in his pants
all right that's going too far
but
that's too much for you yeah and that's
how you know it's bad yes but hey maybe
we're being too hard on hunter maybe his
paintings just need better marketing
thank the lord the day i found hunter
biden's artwork as i was aging the pain
in my hips was getting worse and worse
but since i started using hunter's art i
am pain free and the best thing is i get
to play with my grandchildren again
thanks hunter you see this original
hunter biden artwork i take this every
day i used to be in pain and now i'm the
ambassador to volaris
i'm hunterbot just because my art is
being sold anonymously and without
transparency doesn't mean that it's not
going to work for you
plus every art piece comes in one of
these handy dandy shipping tubes
reusable for many things
we have somebody on our staff who can
play hunter biden
no one told me this we could have
started that months ago
cat
i think what bothers me most about under
is that he can have fun despite all the
the trail of dis the trail of hell that
he leaves behind he has no consciousness
i'm jealous no i was yes i think
everyone needs to admit that we are all
a little jealous
we are right there's there's no
depravity that he's not like he's like
forget the crack he banged his brother's
widow oh
and everyone's related as well and
everyone's like you poor complicated
beautiful soul yes like he bangs his
brother's widow and then he can spit on
a canvas and get half a million dollars
no i know when i spit people are like
you need to get out of here yes
it's i'm jealous and people who say
they're not jealous they're lying yes i
think
he's he is joe the perfect example of a
man with no regrets it's like this is
how they live correct
when it's his time to go what is he
going to say he wish he had done yeah
what's left yeah i mean
it used to be once all your teeth fell
out people said you're good yeah you're
finished with the parting that was just
the star trek exactly now he's this
amazing artist first of all these are
this is the worst money laundering
operation here cause usually when people
buy art they don't have a palm full of
cash and handed teams say go get
yourself something nice that's not
usually how artists transact
or on the other hand it just made me
realize maybe all art sucks yeah that's
true i've seen the elephants painting
they're better than his no it's actually
a good point kt maybe what hunter is
doing is a gift for all of us he's
showing you how easy it is to scam the
art world or is he just living off his
dad oh my god okay so what this is all
about is if you're a foreign country or
a foreign company or a rich foreigner
you cannot donate or give money to an
american political officer or american
political candidate this is their
workaround right so a lot of the money
it's not coming from people who
otherwise are going to donate to the
campaign this is coming from foreigners
china china china who are trying to buy
favor and get access to debt
it's amazing though i have to say david
uh
you are you got to be jealous you know
here's a guy with so little talent that
just continued to fail upward
unlike you exactly like why can't i
stumble into that yes
but you know so that i think you guys
are giving them
they're not he's not the the influence
peddling yeah i think that's overblown
really this shows how far he's fallen
really you know a few years ago he was
you know doing drugs in a ukrainian
private plane
having the time of his life and now he's
just like hey look what i drew yeah
ukrainians are like oh great hunter put
on the fridge
his art why didn't he do the
i want to advise him it's like you
should what you should have done okay
you should not be in painting your
medium should be laptops right
be like banksy you leave them all over
the city yeah you know
and then it kind of makes the other ones
like oh is that just art yeah that's
true that that's what it was all about
it's actually performance art yeah or a
kind of a mix of technology and
performance art but i don't think he
thinks that way i don't think he thinks
no yeah that's the secret of happiness
joe you just blast through it
lasts right through it i really think
that if we do a couple more positive
segments about him he's going to do the
show i admire him
i've done a complete one is it a 180 or
360. yo 360. 360 you'd be back where you
started yeah which is the story of my
life
i wouldn't it's like i've been making
fun of this guy forever and then i
realized that maybe he's right and i'm
wrong you just
you just exploit everybody around you
just burn through them
at first i didn't know that they were
all different laptops and when they were
releasing the pictures i thought how
much memory is on this hard drive
that it's got different folders for like
here's prostitutes here's homemade
pornography he's at least he's organized
yes
last word david
greg you know how you get them on the
show how go buy a painting
there you go
see that's why you're sitting over there
thank you yes